hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey continuing our reviews
from the spot you always see us at yay
mixing it up in no way possible anyway
we're gonna talk about the most ultimate
of Valentine's Day movies a Lita battle
angel because sure there's romance in it
more like a leader romance angel no yes
oh yeah yes yeah listen before we hop
into this review I wanted to say a
special thank you to everyone who has
been downloading and following us on the
Stardust app that stuff is so free that
it doesn't cost any money to do it isn't
that ridiculous its 30-second reactions
reviews for films TV shows and trailers
post daily you can also post on there as
well and even tag us and maybe we'll
look at it so download the app do it
today let's talk about Ally to battle
angel so if you haven't seen any of the
highly praised trailers for Ally to
battle angel here's the description I am
nipa a deactivated female cyborg is
revived if it wasn't a female would it's
a male we cannot remember anything of
her past life and goes on a quest I'm
just so feminist to find out who she is
so this is a long work in progress it's
based on a famous manga James Cameron
wrote and produced this movie Rob
Rodriguez directed it supposedly this
weekend it's going to bomb so bad that's
what everyone says so this review should
skyrocket through the roof right now my
initial reaction throughout most of this
movie but especially we were conversing
with people after it was done and real
quick I just want to say thank you to
for tx4 looking up a screening I do feel
and there were plenty of people who like
you know you always talk to the 40x
people then you talk to the people after
when the 40x people aren't around it
wasn't unanimous
there was in agreeance the 40x does
elevate the experience quite a lot oh
yeah so if you want to get your best
experience possible I would say 40 exits
with like the motion chairs the strobe
lights I'm sure we're showing images
over us talking right now to compensate
for the lack of being able to articulate
the experience so watch it this is the
kind of movie of 40 X is made for I did
feel as elevated but even if I hadn't
seen it on 40 X I would still probably
have the same opinion which is I agree
with everyone that's what I'm describing
my opinion about this movie is I heard
two reviews normally I don't listen to
reviews of the movies before I go watch
them and I was like it's just a lead of
battle angels I watched screen junkies
news which had Dan and Roth who like
really did not like this movie like they
really did it and then I heard Chris
Tuckman's review who was a lot more on
the positive side in it and his
reasonings for why he might have been a
little bit more biased and other critics
because he's familiar with the manga
he's a big anime fan in general yada
yada yada there's a couple people who
are familiar with that specific one and
his anime in general say that that is a
particular point this movie satisfying
yeah aggressive comics noted that saying
if you watch our trailer reactions I've
always had big hopes for this movie when
it first came out around Tomatoes it was
like a 30% now it's at like 60 something
percent it's been hovering it's 60 ohms
so my expectations for this film went in
just appropriated enough it was like
okay it sounds like he's gonna give me
100% what I want which is just a fun
time nothing more there will be some
things that are good about it maybe some
things that don't work so I agree with
everyone every flaw I've heard about
this film trying to set up too much over
convoluted it's all there it's like so
there especially in the finale where
like the last 20 to 30 minutes are just
so ridiculously rushed to be jam-packed
wrap up this story a lot of logical plot
whole things or you're like we didn't
need to do that and a lot of setting up
for sequels we were like okay so a lot
of this that we saw wasn't even
necessary it's just a set of for a
sequel but there's also plenty of good
things in this
movie that I really did enjoy I really
liked Rosa Salazar in the film so
charming and somewhat isn't like it's
not a stiff character like how the
trails might lead you to believe of a
girl who might might smile and wonder
but is overall kind of a stiff performer
she has a lot of personality in the
movie Christoph Waltz who is probably
the greatest supporting actor to have
ever existed shows up for these little
parts man but he gives them his bad
villainous or good guy he's just such a
good supporting actor everything he does
and he's a - Oscars over it no but he's
great like he really does show up no
matter what the role isn't he was one of
my favorite parts of this actually even
ed skrein was I thought was a really
standout character in the movie I
thought the world was so cool you know
like there are people who can be so
dazzled by like the world of avatar or
Aquaman and that alone is enough to make
them recommend the movie or love it for
its designs like love it for those
elements and I found myself maybe
because I'm a naturally a sucker for
sci-fi films
looking at the designs the aesthetics
the world of this it didn't wear off on
me you know like usually it's like
alright a guy you suit after 20 minutes
and it's whatever now and it's like it's
always a present but it's whatever
throughout this movie I would constantly
find myself going man that looks so cool
that is just so cool what they did well
I think part of what enhances that
aspect is one thing I think this movie
does get right is is fleshing out its
world in a way that doesn't seem as
gimmicky as it could because you know
you see all these spectacular places and
structures but you also get to meet who
inhabits them and see what different
jobs there are through some of the main
characters and stuff like that and so
yeah like the cyberpunk world that they
create you know so many movies have aid
to this kind of thing out of anime
before but it really is like a dazzling
world and it's realized I thought in a
satisfying mix of CG and practical sets
and things like that well yeah because a
lot of them are cyborgs with human
elements and there are others where it's
a little bit muddied in terms of are
they human who got a lot of cyborg
upgrades you know sometime it's a little
confusing in that department you
definitely feel some of the rieta ting
on this movie because there's a lot of
famous actors who show up there are some
where they're intentionally famous to be
teased for sequel and there are some we
were like I've seen you in so many movie
like this is that whole bar scene yeah
that you see in the trailer when had
scurry touches her and she does that
thing where she goes up to his neck and
throws it down yeah but it's able Ted
the blood or that whole bar scene they
cut around to a lot of different Hunter
characters as they call them and you're
like man these guys probably all have
roles that are just not in this movie
you know it was probably a much longer
scene before there are a lot of moments
like that where you could tell like I
bet that guy was supposed to continue
talking or I bet this scene was a lot
longer at first yeah hasn't be a little
random and it's just kind of the sliver
any flaw that have I've been told about
this and it just showed from every
review I've heard it showed after the
screening was done and listening to
everyone's opinions not one part of me
wanted to go you're wrong or I disagree
it's just which side of the scale will
your feelings ultimately land is that
the things you like about the movie
well that ultimately outweigh the things
you don't like about the movie and for
me personally the things I've liked I
really took away a lot from it you know
yeah like my girlfriend said I felt like
a CW show and I'm like cool yeah I feel
you on that and it's like there's so
many elements are corny the one thing
that I really because a lot of this is
just me going yeah whatever
not that's stupid yeah like brushing it
off the one element that I really just
did not care for was the element with
the the love interest Hugo which sucks
because the guy is really giving it his
all and he does a fine job he's not bad
in the movie was can Johnson doesn't
yeah yeah yeah he's fine in the movie he
shows up looking exactly like Robert
Rodriguez at first to with like the fire
and the weather jack in the Forbidden
Kingdom oh my god I mean he looks kinda
like Michael anger the thing is the
movie gives a lot of focus to it and it
really wants you to care yeah and I just
don't care yeah I mean the thing is yeah
he's got some charm and I I found myself
enjoying some of their scenes together
despite
how cheese like some of that stuff is
the cheesiest of the movie but at the
same time yeah it's like it doesn't get
deep enough to really merit being this
focal thing but it is kind of fun and
charming I guess yeah it feels very
familiar and it's nothing more than a
bunch of other romances of this variety
you've seen a thousand times and that's
kind of its major sin you know boiler
plate there were times where I felt like
this movie was kind of pushing some of
its feminist angles which was fine by me
but the thing that was conflicting with
specifically with the romantic element
was because she's just like because such
a little girl about him so early on and
obsessed it and loved it I'm like why
distracting to me about it yeah there's
a lot of performers in here who are or
find is just not utilized well literally
every flaw you've heard I'm here just to
tell you everything you've heard is true
is there a lot of things that are
lackluster in terms of like the emirate
all these fine but yeah a lot of people
could have done that role Jennifer
Connelly fine a lot of people go down
that role that's the way it is for a lot
of people but the thing is I think
there's plenty of great things in this
movie that warrant a viewing experience
and it's just up to you if you like
literally don't expect a deep film and
you just want to have fun because
there's action scenes in here that are
just incredible there are like
incredible action moments in here and
the visuals are sowed and like this
movie sets out to give you a cool visual
world it's not as deep as it wants to be
it is muddy but I wouldn't mind watching
sequel and the day and age were like the
barriers are so thin you can count on
the idea that they will hear and take
some constructive criticism yeah I
walked out of this feeling like this is
kind of a mess but it's a mess that's
got enough stuff that I enjoyed or saw
the potential and that I would love to
return yeah to the world to the story
because the action is really dazzling
too that's probably the most
consistently quality thing about this
movie is that there's not really one
action scene I can think of where I was
like he's got a very punchy direction--
style and it comes out I noticed during
the action especially because he directs
that stuff with energy but in a way
where you can always tell what's
happened and I so appreciate it it
really shows how good he is at working
with a CG and green screens and effects
but also marrying them to worlds and you
know and so I feel like that saves a lot
of this because on the story in the
technical side there's like just as much
good as bad in almost every other
department you know now tell you this
I've seen quite a few movies lately that
are over convoluted fantastic piece to
we're like over convoluted and it's
boring a [ __ ] and then you get Aquaman
where people are kind of split on how
like I recommend that movie I like but
I'm also they're going I didn't really
feel much when I watched it I feel like
technically Aquaman's a better movie but
I felt a little more when I watch this
movie yeah I with a greater sense of joy
because I think there's something
satisfying about the fact that this is a
scrappy movie but at its core there's
something good and there's a while yeah
you know it's also something that's a
little bit new and it's of a style that
is trying to find it's happening and I
feel like for anime adaptations in some
ways this is the closest we've gotten to
a quality one and so I feel like that
edge also kind of puts me in the same
position as you where I've seen a lot of
this kind of thing lately and this is I
like it it's scrappy but I like and
before I wrap this video up I want your
page in the day shout-out to a lovely
woman named Adelia Chamberlain Adelia
mcdeere we've been talking quite a bit
you saying how you were kind of looking
forward to this room you don't know how
to feel about we've had some
conversations about this film and I'm
hoping that you get a chance to go watch
this movie you're one of my favorite
people in the world I really look
forward to every message that we could
have with each other over at patreon you
are such a sweetheart and you know what
in a lot of ways you are the battle
angel for our channel man
delia battling it's perfect he finished
it John it's what I'd add a li OOP did
dude and I just dunked it right in for
you that's what you did we dunk you we
dunk you that's gonna be a new t-shirt
you're the first girl to get dunked on
our first person to get dunked yeah
anyway guys you can subscribe to the
react nation click that notification
down and false in the Stardust app and
join us on patreon and maybe
don't